good afternoon my name is adrian dix i'm
bc's minister of health to my right is
dr bonnie henry bc's provincial health
officer this is our code 19 briefing for
bc for wednesday february the 9th we're
honored to be here on the territory of
the long and speaking people of the
sangees and the esquimalt first nations
and with that it's my honor to introduce
dr bonnie henry
thank you very much and good afternoon
i would like to start today by
recognizing
the tragedy that we are continuing to
experience
earlier today
our corner vc's corner released the
report on illicit drug toxicity deaths
in bc in 2021
and as we know our province has lost
another 2
24
people to toxic drugs last year these
are our brothers our sisters our family
members our colleagues our friends
and it is such a challenging thing to
know that no matter what we do it's
still
affecting all of us
i remain firm in my commitment from our
office to do everything we can
to continue to do to try and find ways
to help people who use drugs
to reduce that shame and stigma that
keeps people who use drugs from reaching
out to their friends and their loved
ones
and part of that is continuing to push
health canada
with the
exemption so that decriminalization of
people who use drugs is a key
role that we can do and as well we're
moving ahead and pushing on increasing
access for people to a safer supply of
drugs during this incredibly toxic time
especially now as we're seeing increased
mixed drugs including benzodiazepines
that makes it even more challenging to
rescue people
it has also become very apparent
that our two health crises are
intertwined
and getting through
this next phase and getting through the
pandemic emergency of covid19 is also
vital to helping us manage people who
are caught up in our toxic drug crises
but please know you are not alone
and reach out reach out to people let
them know do not use alone
and we will get through this
we have also continued as you know to
monitor our progress through this
pandemic
including reviewing our orders on an
ongoing basis and as always we are
reevaluating all of the measures that we
have in place
the data that we have that shows where
we are in this wave as we move through
yet another changing
virus
i want people to know that all of these
changes that we make to orders to easing
of restrictions
were are done because of the how we have
worked together to get through this last
two years
and i recognize and we see this all
around us we're all tired of this we
want it to end but wanting it to end and
taking the right measures to get us
through this
is uh are two different things that we
need to work on together
and i want you to know that the changes
that will be made will be continued to
be based on the science the
circumstances of our pandemic here in
british columbia and a direct result of
the millions of people in bc who have
done and continue to do everything they
can to protect themselves their
neighbors their communities and that's
how we will get through this it has been
a long
changing two years as we adjust to the
curves that this virus has shown us
that the reasons we are coping
right now
with this
omicron rave again a different
virus that has been
a challenge is in different ways for us
is because we are continuing to support
each other as families as communities
across this province the public health
tools we have been using like case and
contact management the type of testing
that we're doing those have had to
change and that is challenging it's hard
for us to to change our our tactics as
we're going through this changing
environment as well but we continue to
use those measures that work for us
individually and collectively
whether it's
making sure that you're vaccinated
getting your booster dose
making sure you're staying away from
others if you're feeling unwell
washing your hands regularly
all of these things wearing masks when
we're in indoor public places these are
all things right now that are going to
get us through this wave
and as we are transitioning
we will get to that point where we can
have a sustainable management strategy
we're working through the details of
this following every day
what we are seeing in our hospitals what
we're seeing in our communities
and we'll be sharing specifics in the
next week as you know the the
number of the orders are expiring next
week and we will
continue to monitor those
what you will hear next week will be the
details of how we're going to be moving
forward
more you will hear less about the
pandemic as we get through this wave and
more about how we continue to manage our
personal risks
as restricted restrictions are adjusted
in step with what we are seeing in terms
of transmission and hospitalizations
as well we'll be modifying our
surveillance reports
and looking at what are the important
things that we need to monitor and
what's the time frame we need to monitor
those in
as you know we've changed our testing
strategy
to focus on those people who need a test
because it affects their health
management or because it's important for
them in terms of
returning to work
and because of that a couple of the
metrics that we've been reporting on
daily
particularly um
the the ones
about active cases and
people who have been removed from
isolation are no longer accurate and
they're no longer an accurate reflection
of what's happening in the community so
those ones will be removed from our
daily surveillance reports and off of
the dashboard on the bccdc website
again it's a change because of the
changing strategies and how we're
dealing with what we're faced with right
now
it's important not to lose sight of the
fact that covet 19 continues to be a
serious respiratory illness and we will
be focusing on that and needs to be
treated as that and the virus is not
going away we can expect that it will
change in the future we only need to
look at the amount of transmission
around the world and what has happened
in the last few months with the
delta wave and now omicron to know that
we are still at risk of having yet
another variant arise that we will need
to manage and one of the most important
things that we have now on our side is
that tool of protection through
vaccination so we need to make sure that
we are monitoring that and the
effectiveness of our vaccine programs
the effectiveness of our boosters and
the immunity as we move forward
but we also know
that we have a higher level of immunity
now across bc because people have been
immunized and that gives us an
opportunity to look at changes to how
we're managing in the weeks ahead
a few days ago the national advisory
committee on immunization provided
updated guidance on vaccinations and
boosters
for people who have had a previous covet
19 infection
and this is a complicated thing there is
no definitive right answer for what is
the optimal time to get vaccinated after
you've been in had an infection what we
do know
from real world data and we've said this
multiple times
is that at least in the short term
people who've been infected with covid19
have had an infection do generally have
some degree of immunity that lasts for
several weeks to months
but it is very variable and we're seeing
that more and more with omicron as well
that people who are not vaccinated can
have a very mild illness and they may
not develop both parts of the immune
system so the the what we call the
humeral immunity the antibodies in her
blood and the the longer lasting
stronger protection you get from cell
mediated immunity
so we do know it's less clear for
omicron how much protection and how long
it lasts
we also know from immunology and
vaccinology and what we know about the
expanded intervals that it is important
to wait a period of time between doses
and that helps that cell-mediated
immunity become stronger and longer
lasting
so the guidance really confirms the
importance of even if you have had an
infection that it is important to build
up and strengthen your immune system for
the long term through vaccination so if
you have not yet been vaccinated and you
have been infected recently with omicron
or with delta in the last few months you
can wait as long as eight weeks until
you start your your immunization
those ones and those twos
or you can wait eight weeks between your
first and second dose
after infection but what this does is it
does mean you will have some degree of
risk in that period of time so it really
depends on how much virus is circulating
in the community which strain of the
virus it is
and also really important things like
who you live with and how what risk they
might be if you become infected right
now
so what we have been saying what i have
been saying all along is that it is
important that once you have recovered
from infection and are no longer
infectious to others that you can
receive your vaccine any time after that
if you are somebody who's immune
compromised or has risk factors for
severe illness
that is when you should get your vaccine
and this applies to booster doses too so
if you are at six months from when
you've had your second dose regardless
of whether you've had an infection if
you have those underlying conditions
that make you more at risk it's
important to get your booster dose right
away
if you are otherwise healthy you can
wait as long as three months after
that infection so all of this is
slightly confusing
i will tell you that we have increasing
evidence and i talked about the puzzle
that we were putting together around
omicron we do know now that that third
dose that boosts your dose does increase
your protection probably about 50 to 60
protection from infection with omicron
so we know now that two doses does give
really good strong longer lasting
protection against severe illness like
hospitalizations that leads to
hospitalizations or deaths
and that continues but that can be
boosted and the protection against
infection can be boosted with that third
dose
so right now with the amount of
transmission that we're seeing the
advice that i give to people
is that it is important to get that
booster dose at six months right now
regardless of whether you've had a mild
omicron infection in the last few weeks
as we get to a place where there's less
virus circulating that advice may change
and it may be prudent or it may be okay
to wait a little bit longer
but i encourage everybody when there's a
lot of virus around vaccination helps
so get it when you recover
whether that's your dose one your dose
two or at six months your booster dose
uh as i mentioned we're revising our
orders and we've been working with
industry particularly the food and
beverage industry and i just want uh
people to know we will be posting
additional guidance uh under the food
and and look or serving premises order
um basically at the request of industry
to support businesses that don't
normally serve food
so that's bars and nightclubs in
in general and from the very beginning
they have been able to repurpose their
business or re-orient their business to
serve food
and
there's been more interest in that in
the last few weeks since we
changed the orders around
liquor serving premises
and so we've been working on this
consultation with industry and we'll be
providing the clarification of what they
need to do to be able to serve food
in those premises
as well
in follow-up to the notice that was
given in october
we are moving ahead
with the new order in place for
regulated health professionals
i have spoken many times about the
importance of all of us as health care
professionals doing everything we can
and it is our obligation to make sure
that we're taking all of the measures to
protect
those patients in our care especially
the more vulnerable people that we serve
as well it is important for us to
protect our own health as part of being
able to continue to contribute into the
health care
of others during this challenging time
it is our responsibility and it
continues to be our responsibility and
vaccination as part of that in fall in
the fall as you know we put orders and
measures in place for all health care
workers working in long-term care acute
care and community health settings
and uh for several months now we've been
working with the health professional
colleges to sort through the details of
that vaccine requirement that we gave
notice on in october
it's ensuring that we have a consistent
supported standard across healthcare so
that all regulated health professionals
are held to the same standard
and so
i had given notice in the order in
october that we would give a date once
when that would be required and so that
date will now be march 24th
2022
we're taking a phased approach so that
those few individuals who are not yet
vaccinated are able to have that
opportunity to get their vaccines
and there is a process in place for
medical exemptions that can be submitted
to my office
colleges will then work with the
registrants who are unvaccinated
to support them through this process so
those orders
will be
in place starting next week once we've
had the final consultations with the
colleges
i think this is a really important
measure that brings the same standard to
all healthcare workers across the
province and is one of the most
important measures that has allowed us
to manage through this omicron wave
where we have seen such a high rate of
hospitalized high number of
hospitalizations
and will help protect us from the
unknowns that are certain to happen in
the coming year
we are getting through this pandemic
but we are not through it yet here in bc
or globally we are progressing because
we are looking out for each other taking
care of each other and because we have
that definitive tool of vaccination
we are weathering this omicron storm it
is because of the high level of
protection we have from the immunization
in british columbia and from the
measures millions of people in this
province are taking every day
this has meant our health care workers
have had milder illness so that we're
able to get back to work
and while the rates of hospitalization
and the rates of people dying have been
much much less because
of
the
because of vaccination and the severity
of illness from omicron what we continue
to see is that absolute numbers are
still staggering and we see that in
with the high number of people who still
have dying from covered right now
and it is still affecting people
differentially people who are
unvaccinated our elders and seniors
continue to be overly represented in
severe illness and deaths
we are not in the same place everywhere
in bc we know that this wave has passed
through in the lower mainland ahead of
other parts of the province and we are
still stretched very thin we are also in
a different place than many other
jurisdictions both globally and across
canada and we will
continue to monitor our situation and
adjust our measures here in accordance
to what we're seeing but i also know
that we are very proud and how we are
working together to keep our businesses
open across the board keeping schools
child care centers open and we will be
in a better place very soon
this will be a gradual process
finding that balance over this next
phase of transition in the next few
months and weeks
but we can look to tomorrow
with hope and optimism and continuing
with kindness and with care thank you
thank you very much
dr henry and
i wanted to
provide an update on vaccination on
rapid tests on uh surgical renewal and
on the impact of sickness on our health
care system and on health care workers
with respect to vaccinations today we've
uh we're now the point of 11 over 11
million administered doses in bc which
is
an extraordinary achievement of
healthcare workers of
all of the staff surrounding and
supporting our immunization efforts of
pharmacists and community pharmacy of
people who came and and got vaccinated
in their massive majority more than
93 percent less than seven percent of
people who now or of adults less than
have uh
have only seven percent to six point
eight percent i think have not received
their first dose immunization from covet
19. so it has been a joint effort and
it's an extraordinary effort what we've
seen um for all adults for example is 93
percent as i say 93.2 first dose 91
second dose now well over 50 54
have received
their booster dose amongst all adults in
vc and those numbers are growing every
day i had the occasion this weekend to
visit two
vaccination centers over uh over a
couple of days and
and uh talk in advance before the doors
open to
the health care workers and those
supporting them at vaccination centers
everywhere i talked to
a naturopathic doctor who's been
vaccinating the italian cultural center
throughout the pandemic who's vaccinated
people the youngest person he'd
vaccinated was five the oldest was 106.
and how moved and inspired he was by his
participation in this extraordinary
public health effort all i can do is
express my gratitude to people of bc
healthcare workers in bc and our teams
around the vaccination centers who've
done an exceptional job
thank you thank you thank you
i wanted to bring an update on the
impact of sickness uh on health care
workers in the health care system
health authorities continue to closely
monitor sickness levels across health
services especially in hospitals in
long-term care and in home support i can
report from the that the week of january
31st to february 6
17 158 health care workers called in
sick
that com is down slightly from the
previous week where the number was
seventeen thousand seven hundred and
fifty six
that's three thousand seven hundred and
sixty eight in fraser health
three thousand three hundred and eighty
nine in interior health
one thousand 1702 in northern health
1713 in the provincial health services
authority that includes bc emergency
health services
2450 in vancouver coastal health 3427
in ireland health and 709 in providence
healthcare i want to express again my
gratitude to all those health care
workers for their endurance and skill
and meeting this challenge which is an
extraordinary one for people across
the public health care system
i want to provide an update on rapid
tests
we expect to see by the end of february
so they're not here yet
25 million 652 000
rapid tests arrive in bc
25 million six hundred and fifty two
thousand
clearly the supply of tests to bc is
ramping up quickly in the in the two
weeks ahead we need to continue to
ensure easy access to rapid antigen
tests for those at higher risk for coli
to ensure timely access to treatment and
we will be taking measures to protect
some of the supply to meet their needs
in the weeks and months to come
however with the expected increase in
supply we will be working over the days
to come on a larger distribution
approach and we will have more to say
about that in the next week or so
as of february 5th 2022 bc had received
12 million 444 000 rapid tests including
two million and seventy thousand that
arrived in the last couple of days
uh six million five hundred and seventy
five thousand seven hundred thirty two
tests have been deployed to key
strategic areas that leaves a current
inventory of 5 million 869 000 tests
over the next two weeks so they're going
out now from february 8th to 19th
subject to the timely delivery in the
future
but these rapid tests in particular have
arrived we will be delivering 4 million
130 000 test kits in addition to what's
already been delivered so that's 400 000
dakova testing centers to replenish
supply 860 000 to visitors and
symptomatic staff and long-term care and
assisted living that's part of our
continuing effort in addition to
continuing to existing supply a hundred
thousand to resupply uh um acute care
centers for symptomatic health care
workers and health authority programs
240 000 to rural remote and indigenous
communities
1 million 300 000 more test kits to
support k-12 education 780 000 to
post-secondary education the remaining
tests will be distributed to
point-of-care screening program and
health authority programs
again we'll be providing more details on
how we deal with the next that will take
us past 11 million of the 12 million we
have now and then with the additional
that are coming we expect coming in the
next couple of weeks we will have more
details on our on our much larger
distribution plan in the coming week
and now just a an update on surgical
renewal uh health authorities report
that 6 231 surgeries were completed from
january 9th to january 15th
from
january 30th to february 5th most recent
period health authorities postponed 548
non-urgent scheduled surgeries that's 72
in fraser health 400 in interior health
62 in island health five in northern
health nine in the provincial health
services authority
we're seeing across bc and we continue
to see the impact of covet 19 on their
staff and i want to particularly note
the efforts in interior health you'll
know both in terms of health healthcare
worker days loss but also in terms of
surgeries cancelled that's where we're
facing some of our biggest challenges
and where the staff at interior health
continues to go above and beyond the
call
to work
on behalf of all the people in the
region and we are very appreciative and
admiring of those efforts from susan
brown on down
cumulatively from september 5th to
february 5th regional surges of coven 19
and factors including severe weather
patterns have caused 7
277 surgical postponements when it comes
to our health care system and supporting
it we've said on a number of occasions
that our work is not done and today's
surgical renewal update fits that same
bill our work is not done
when it comes to stopping kovid's rapid
spread our work is not done because our
work makes a critical difference there's
a lot of talk i think and some talk
about
changes that are that may be coming and
how
and and why such changes would be
happening when we succeed in british
columbia and when we've succeeded
it's because we've worked together
all of our successes as a province
all of the efforts we've made to support
one another have made a difference
in bc i think one of the leaders in the
world in vaccination
we have consistently as a people and
everyone points to exception but
consistently followed public health
guidance and public health orders and
supported one another in these times and
it's made a difference
so when we make announcements
that allow us to do things we may not
have done before
it's because of those people in
particular the 93 percent of people with
their first dose immunization the health
care workers who have gone
above and beyond the call and have given
everyone the best possible care in the
world against covet 19 our record in
critical care shows that it is
outstanding
these are things that we've done
together and what makes it when we do
have successes
what makes those successes special is
because we did them together and i want
to thank all of you today
and say that when when we look at this
and we look at changes that come
and whether we like those changes we
don't like those changes
the successes we have are our successes
and we need to continue to build on that
spirit as a province as a people and as
a health care system in the days and
weeks and the months to come
thank you very much we're happy to take
your questions
a reminder to reporters on the line
please press star one to enter the queue
you'll be limited to one question and
one follow-up our first question today
goes to von palmer vancouver's son
a good day dr henry these
vaccination mandates for medical
professionals when you first
announced that these were coming last
october 5th
you indicated they could be out within a
few days um
healthcare workers have been
facing
layoffs without pay for weeks
since last fall really
why has it taken so long to get the
health professionals in line on this and
to get them to agree to it
when other healthcare workers have been
subjected to this for weeks
yeah so these are all the same
healthcare workers so as you know there
are some people a smaller proportion of
them who are not involved in the other
orders that we have out and that's why i
put that in
the the broader healthcare worker orders
that they were on notice about that so
it's not
the colleges have all been
behind this and we've been working very
closely on them it turned out to be much
more complex than we originally thought
and it really was about how do we
determine who's a registrant of which
college and how do we determine
vaccination rates how do we make it
practical and operational to be able to
understand
immunization status of registrants so it
really was
technical operational issues behind the
scenes it was not the intent
the intent has been agreed to from the
very beginning and it is an important
long-term strategy it is what has gotten
us through
this far the the mandates particularly
if we look at for example long-term care
how important it has been to have that
level of protection the best that we
possibly can for every healthcare
provider and it's about providing
protection to the public so yes we've
been had an ongoing and some of it is
legalese around how the colleges are
organized and
and some of them are going through
transitions so it will affect things
like bylaws and how those
are
um in the future and i really do believe
it is a strong basis for something that
we have been talking about for a long
time which is the importance of us as
healthcare professionals regulated
health professionals um to do everything
we can do to protect ourselves and our
patients and part of that is about
immunization not just for covet but for
other things that we know can be spread
in a healthcare setting so
that's a future discussion whether we're
talking influenza measles other
important
vaccine-preventable diseases as well
vaughn do you have a follow-up
yes please
there have been several media reports
recently
about
doctors here in bc and elsewhere but
here in bc
spreading
quite disturbing misinformation
about covet 19 and about vaccines
does that concern you and is are the is
the college of physicians and surgeons
dealing with this problem are they are
they calling these people to account for
this
yes uh does it disturb me absolutely it
does i think it's
it's reprehensible to be honest to
spread uh what is clearly
untruths
and particularly when people have very
legitimate concerns and questions about
these vaccines and to be out there
saying that as and calling yourself a
legitimate health care professional in
this province or in this country is
really um very much a concern i know
there has been complaints at least i've
read about that to the college
about the professional practice the
college has had put out um standards and
i can't speak for how they're dealing
with this but i do think it is very
clear and
talking with some of my colleagues in
first nations
where
misinformation and truly lies have been
spread that causes fear that leads to
people not taking preventive action not
protecting themselves and that has led
to serious illness and deaths in people
and i put that
squarely at the hands of people who are
spreading this type of misinformation so
yes you can see that i i think it is a
very um
egregious breach of our responsibilities
as healthcare professionals
and yes the college has a process to
deal with complaints the college of
physicians and surgeons in the other
colleges i would say that as you know we
announced the
requirement for vaccination i believe it
was august to be put in place when it
was put in place both in long-term care
first and then
across the healthcare system and is to
put in context how many people that
applied to is about 50 000 people in
long-term care i think was 48 000 but
138 at 30 000 or roughly 128 000 i guess
people across the health care system so
that applied to that group the supplies
uh and so many of those of course the
large share of those are members of
healthcare of health professional
colleges already and and have already
are dealing with the vaccine
requirements so this is the additional
and i think dr henry would say that i
think as well though there's been very
strong support amongst the health
professional colleges working through it
to ensure that
the this
requirement applies to all health
professions and it will and obviously
those issues are things that
issues around
the advice being provided by registrants
are issues that the colleges deal with
and deal with on a regular basis so the
college probably won't comment on
existing proceedings at this point we
are also making some significant changes
to the system of health professional
colleges as you know and we'll expect to
see those
uh fairly soon that will both reduce the
number of colleges and increase our
ability to work through these issues in
a clear and transparent way and we will
next question we go to richard sussman
global news
just logistically to that point to
minister are all the colleges listed on
the bc website are all of the people who
work within those colleges now required
to be under the mandate and a more
philosophical question uh there has been
you know a lot of talk over the last few
days about vaccine mandates and other
jurisdictions uh both globally and here
in canada
where
largely people are getting rid of
vaccine mandates rather than putting
them in even here kevin macleod a
well-known doctor and a presence on
social media writes vaccine mandates
additionally made sense i supported them
at this stage of the pandemic they do
not make sense
so what is the justification for
continuing mandates not just for workers
but for the general public
and then just
hopefully some nuts and bolts on exactly
who falls under this
yeah so i can tell you it's all of the
regulated health professionals under the
regulated health professionals act um so
that includes a whole list and we'll be
putting out a bulletin that has all of
those listed just to make it easier for
you but it does include everybody under
the regulated health professions act
in terms of of mandates i think there's
a lot of disparate voices out there that
are using the term to mean different
things so these uh in terms of vaccine
mandates for health care workers in a
health care setting we also know that
there are mandates for many other
settings where it is both a workplace
issue
where it's a protection of your
colleagues and doing the best that we
can to have a safe workplace those types
of mandates are very effective and we've
seen that what we have seen is uh people
are changing uh the uh
the use of things like the bc vaccine
card
and again also a very effective tool
that has was not meant and is not meant
in bc to be uh there forever and that's
why we've put end dates on the bc
vaccine card so that is a different
mandate and i think those two messages
have been
put together in terms of
where somebody who's vaccinated to what
activities they can access and how so
there are a number of different
things put together in that
we do see both of those as being
effective tools in certain aspects and
certainly it is the vaccine mandate in
healthcare that has made a huge
difference in our ability to manage
through this wave and i some people say
you know omicron is
so transmissible and vaccines are not
preventing all of the transmission which
is absolutely true and we do get a boost
to that prevention of transmission when
people get their booster dose
but it is giving very strong protection
against
hospitalization and severe illness from
people who would have and if i think
about this if we did not have the level
of immunity in our province because so
many people have the protection from
vaccines and omicron was the first
strain out of the gate we would be in
very dire straits
and you just can't imagine it
if we're looking at right now the
percent of people who you know the rate
of hospitalization is about a third of
what we were seeing with delta
um but the numbers of people getting
infected
because it can cause breakthrough
infection both from previous infection
and breakthrough infection from
from vaccine
if we had not had that protection of
vaccination or hospitals would have been
flooded as it is the rates of
transmission are markedly lower in
people who are vaccinated and that still
has translated into the largest numbers
of people in hospital that we have seen
and sadly largest numbers of people
dying even though the rate of death from
uh from the omicron infection is so much
lower than what we were seeing with
delta for example so we cannot say that
we would be able to get through this
wave
but the other thing that's really really
important is it has what has allowed us
to get through this but we are not
through this and you just need to talk
to
some of our colleagues
about the evolution of viruses and when
you have this much pressure
because so many people are infected and
the viruses is rapidly uh changing and
mutating the
inevitability that we will see another
variant and that it's the pressure is
for it to be
more transmissible and potentially cause
more severe illness so those are the
things that we have to prepare for your
booster dose today you're getting
vaccinated today is what is going to
keep us
safe and you safe through this next year
that we're still going to be dealing
with this as a global issue
we have such a high rate of of
protection from vaccination
that we are going to i believe have a
period of time that we can regroup and
that we'll be able to do so many more
things together but that's because we've
had vaccine mandates we've because we've
had the effective use of the bc vaccine
card and because people are doing the
right thing in bc
and just one final thing to everybody we
have invitations to book now and those
increased significantly this week
because we were adding a lot of
young people 12 to 17
who are now eligible for booster doses
we have about 850 000 people who've
received invitations who have not yet
booked and we have lots of open
appointments particularly in community
pharmacy
so i include i
i ask people for their
health for the health of the ones they
love and the health of their communities
to book their booster dose appointment
today if they haven't received their
first dose of course to book that
appointment today and i think if you
look at
the order
[Music]
under the order uh regulated health
professionals who are vaccinated with
one dose before march
24 2022 may continue to work as long as
they receive a second dose 28 to 35 days
late after their first dose but that
says that uh that all regulated health
professionals will need to be vaccinated
by march 24 2022 which is which all of
that information including the list of
colleges and health professions
regulated health professionals is in the
information bulletin
richard do you have a follow-up
dr henry you've mentioned a few
different times you know the way that we
contact trace the way that we test it
has changed dramatically
you also keep talking about how these
restrictions and mandates have proven
successful in the past but omicron is
different and the spread is obviously
different now so what data are we
looking at towards the future and what
do you say to industry who's waiting
for next week
with an anticipation that some things
will be eased and others will not what
do you say to them as they try to plan
especially for those industries like
hospitality who have been hit so hard by
this pandemic and have complained often
about how hard it is
to prepare when they're in essence
finding out sort of last minute about
whether they'll be able to resume and in
this case get back to 100 capacity as
some may be anticipating others
may not be anticipating
yeah so i think we've tried to signal uh
where we're going and we look at a whole
variety of things as you know
we're trying to take that focus away
from daily numbers and looking at trends
over time so we are seeing some very
positive signs and trends over time and
that means that some of the measures
that we put in place particularly the
ones that are expiring next week that we
put in place
because we didn't understand
it didn't have all those details of what
omicron was going to look like and
whether that level of immunity we had
was going to be enough to to to keep us
from being swamped if you will but uh so
i think uh i will also say we do have
regular meetings with representatives
from industry and not everybody's
connected to those and i know that means
it challenging and we are still
consulting and going through the
processes with different groups because
as soon as we make one change other
questions come up and that's one of the
things that's reflected today and in the
guidance on how liquor serving
only businesses can provide meals and
why that that's coming up today as
opposed to two weeks ago when we uh had
revised the orders again so it is an
iterative process and an ongoing process
but we are in a relatively positive
place
but not the same everywhere we're still
in a very strained place in interior
health as you know and in parts of the
north so these are all things that we
factor in we look at absenteeism rates
that's one of the things we're measuring
both in schools
in hospitals in workplaces so there are
a number of different factors that go
into the decisions that come in and
i also my team you know we are thinking
longer term where are we in this point
in the pandemic what does it mean that
we've had so many people who now have an
exposure or an experience of of omicron
and thankfully because of this high
level of immunization most of that has
been relatively mild so what does that
mean for schools what does that mean for
workplaces what does that mean for some
of the broader mandates we have in place
and you know obviously i'm looking at
where you know when is the the vc
vaccine car loan no longer needed so
those are things that we're thinking
about over the longer term or the the
next weeks to months
but over the longer term if we think
globally around pandemics and something
that i'm also spend a lot of time
working through and thinking through and
i've talked about this many times how we
look at what's happening in the uk i was
on a call early this morning with israel
about
discussing
what's happening with their pandemic and
what are they seeing so we take the
advice that we're seeing from places
around the world and ours is always a
little bit different
and we try to project what's going to
happen longer term as well
and
as always we are seeing what we have
learned is there's a seasonality
to coronavirus at least in our
hemisphere in our country and so we need
to be able to ensure that we're
preparing and that we have contingency
for the next respiratory season this is
going to be a serious respiratory
illness that is with us at least for
another year
will no more by this time next year
about its patterns
and
we know more in the next few weeks about
how we're going to get through that
next question goes to shannon patterson
i'm c-tv to richard and i'm hoping i can
get a clearer answer the lion king
hospital we are dr kevin mcleod who
treats coco patients himself says it's
time for bc to remove the vaccine
passport requirement for endurance
venues like restaurants because they're
no longer serving their intended purpose
with macron being spread among both
vaccinated and unvaccinated now because
it shouldn't be political and it should
go now so do you think that vaccine
cards do still serve a scientific
medical purpose right now and so what is
that purpose
absolutely from the very beginning
there's two reasons that we have the vc
vaccine card in place one of them of
course is incentives for the
discretionary activities that it applies
to those limited number of discretionary
activities its incentive to encourage
people to be vaccinated that's was
really important especially at first but
it's also
all of those settings and we chose those
particularly are ones that are indoor
settings where we know this spreads more
rapidly and we're seeing that with
omicron so now yes it's a difference um
the difference in spread between
somebody who's vaccinated unvaccinated
it's like i guess it's like saying uh
christine seeing claire and i both play
soccer there's a qualitative difference
to that
um and one of us may be more likely to
score a goal than
the other so when we are looking now at
those settings that are higher risk
indoor settings
yes there's still a risk that people who
are fully vaccinated in those settings
may transmit omicron to each other
but we also know very clearly now that
they're very unlikely to end up with
severe illness and they're unlikely to
end up in our hospitals which is one of
the most important goals that we have
where an unvaccinated person we cannot
say that so it has switched in terms of
not um not solely focusing on reducing
risk of transmission although it does
that particularly if people have their
booster dose on board
but making sure that if we have large
groups of people together in those
indoor settings that we're not going to
have a surge of people hospitalized
because of transmission so there are
different factors that we look at at
different points in this and right now
there is still with the amount i mean
just look at even the the pcr testing
curve that we have which is limited it
doesn't tell us all of transmission in
the community we're still at the highest
levels of transmission we have ever had
in this pandemic
so there is absolutely a purpose to why
we are continuing to use the bc vaccine
card in those specific higher risk
settings
shannon do you have a follow-up
alberta is getting rid of their tonight
at midnight saskatchewan is getting rid
of theirs next monday you had said for
bc it would be the end of june which
would obviously put us three and a half
months later than uh neighboring
provinces here are you comfortable with
bc being that much of an outlier or can
we expect a new timeline next week
i i think we're not the outlier
you know if we think about how many
provinces and territories we have um
on the uh what i've said very clearly
from the beginning that i was extending
it to june 30th and that we would
reevaluate as we go about when it's most
useful and when we can reach that point
of of balancing which has been our
intent the entire time of the need for
it with the amount of transmission and
hospitalizations and deaths that we're
seeing
see
i think this is one of the real
advantages that we've had in bc
with
with dr henry's leadership
you know
you don't want to comment on other
jurisdictions i just say that
significant measures have been announced
and then withdrawn
here in bc
with respect to the bc vaccine card we
said we were going to do it we put it in
place in such a way that it was easy to
download and to use
more than 4 million british columbians
have the bc vaccine card we said we were
going to apply our requirement for
vaccination or proof of vaccination in
the health care system
and we delivered on that and has had
innumerable positive effects for
patients and for health care staff
and there has been fewer changes in
orders in bc we've had as consistent an
approach to public education ensuring
that children to the maximum possible
degree can benefit during a difficult
time pandemic
there has been
consistency and the reason there has
been consistency
has been the thoughtful advice and
guidance
of dr henry
and her team
and that team includes dozens and dozens
of people on the public health side and
of course hundreds of thousands of
people in the health care system side
and all of the other people who have
made these things work like people who
work in grocery stores and people who
work in pharmacy and people who work in
our distribution network well and
everyone else
all of those people have been part of it
so we've con we've had a consistent
approach i know it feels like when
you're here that these are changes
because so much of it has been
unprecedented over two years
but in fact there's been a consistent
thoughtful approach
last week dr henry
talked about what people can expect
around the time the orders
expired gave people lots of notice of
that
and that is because we want to make sure
that people understand what's happening
but i think what you're seeing
is the effect of public health
leadership that has made such a
difference for everyone in bc it's led
by dr henry and she's the public
facebook but i think she'd agree it
includes a huge team of people around
here who've been part of that success
next question kaiden fanshawe ckpg
caden are you on mute
no i am not
thank you we can hear you please go
ahead can you hear me
okay sorry thanks uh for taking my
question i just wanted to get uh dr
henry and minister dix's thoughts on a
situation here in prince doors happened
last weekend
essentially uh a nightclub that had been
ordered closed opened up here
was not shut down uh they were not
letting people in wearing masks they
made you take it off at the door they're
also not checking vaccine passports
um and posting several messages uh about
freedom uh and you know the truck convoy
and stuff as well um they plan to open
back up this weekend um but yeah there's
videos circulating online uh of a ton of
people indoors uh not wearing mask
dancing singing doing all the things
you're not allowed to do but i just
wanted to get dr henry or someone's
thoughts on that
yeah you know
i think um freedom is uh is something
that we can be very proud of what we
have
we can
we have freedom to protest we've seen
that
through many different important issues
over the last little while but we also
have responsibilities to each other and
you know
it's probably when you see those types
of things and people acting out trying
to make their point in their own limited
way
i understand why people do that it can
be frustrating it's tiring it's
hard to go through this but really what
we need to do is
understand that it is all of our
collective actions that are getting us
through this and that make that um you
know
basically a slap in the face to some of
the healthcare workers have been working
so hard for so long
i understand that people are frustrated
and we want to do things that
we have been limited in for the last
little while
but it is because we've pulled together
and we've supported each other and we've
supported those people who continue to
be at high risk and
you know
i don't know what what to say but it is
we see that um some people and i have
had a lot of empathy as you know over
the last two years for younger people
who have had very little control over
things who have had
lack of job prospects and
especially in the hospitality industry
whose universities were shut down for a
period of time who didn't have those
important celebrations in life so
what we need to do is continue
to work together so that we can put this
behind us for once and for all and be
able to support and get back to those
important measures and those important
celebrations in our life soon
i think we all agree that my my freedom
to swing my arm depends on who's
standing in front of me or if anyone's
standing in front of me and i don't have
the freedom to swing my arm
if someone is standing close to me
because they might be hurt and that
would affect
their freedom there is no rights without
responsibilities
and
you know i have to say
that
one of the things that i am most proud
of
of healthcare workers
particularly during the period of the
delta variant where we had large-scale
levels of vaccination a huge number in
that case of unvaccinated people who are
in intensive care across bc there
continues to be to this day a very
significant number of unvaccinated
people in intensive care
people will get the best care possible
and they are the best care in the world
in those circumstances
here in bc by our critical care teams
because we all have
of course
the right to make mistakes
but i think we also have to appreciate
the rights of other people the rights of
people to be treated with respect
in their homes and in their communities
and that includes
ottawa
that includes every every community in
our province to be treated in our
country to be treated with respect
and not to have and so people if people
want to assert their right and
dramatically and negatively affect other
people's basic rights
well
that's not a canadian value that's not
an expression of rights
there are rights and there are
responsibilities
and we have i think in bc
you know and just to put it in context
93.3 percent of people vaccinated 6.8
percent of people not vaccinated there
is a split there but that split is 16 to
one
just to put it in context
and the people who have been vaccinated
have done so for their own safety for
their community safety and i'm very
proud of them that doesn't mean we have
mandatory vaccination we don't accept in
certain circumstances have been defined
by provincial health orders and by
others
but it does mean that we all have those
those uh responsibilities as as though
as with those rights and uh i
i would say to everybody that we need to
think of
other people in our community as well
and i'm proud of the people of bc who
have again and again and again in this
pandemic done that even at cost to
themselves i'm so proud to live in this
place and i'm so proud of them and when
there are successes they are their
successes
kaiden do you have a follow-up
uh yeah yes please yeah thanks for that
um i just wanted to follow up um
obviously many are wondering including
those who went
to
the nightclub and those who may plan to
go to one in the future uh is there any
timeline and there wasn't an end date on
that closure order in particular but is
there any timeline anything better that
you can talk about here today yeah we're
going to be the the gathering and events
orders as you know uh are
coming up for review on the 16th and
we'll be putting out in detail on the
15th
uh what we're doing uh for the next few
weeks
for the next question we go to cole
schissler back black press
uh hi there thanks so much for taking my
question um
so given that disabled people are
disproportionately impacted by covid has
the province been consulting with any
disabled people in public health policy
development and if so
who and if not will the province commit
to consulting with disabled people on
covet policy
yeah we have spent quite a lot of time
with people with disabilities and the
self-advocacy groups
particularly community living bc and in
my office dr danielle bain smith has
been meeting with
the number of advocacy self-advocacy
groups and community living bc on a
weekly basis at least
and we do take a lot of consideration
we prioritize people with disabilities
for vaccination and many
for testing for support we've included
people who work with people with
disabilities particularly in group
housing and other settings in our
vaccine mandates because we recognize
the importance of the care that's
provided by
support workers in those settings and
how it can be a risk and we've been
monitoring
actively
people with disabilities who are
infected who are hospitalized and who've
died from covid and sharing that
information with the the disability
communities and the self-advocates so
that is something we have been working
very and i'm very proud of my team and
the work that they've been doing and and
particularly through community living dc
and then the the teams that um that are
um
affiliated with that uh organization
cool do you have a follow-up
uh yeah so
given that we know that covet and volume
kron especially can be spread through
aerosol transmission which floats in the
air it lingers in spaces i'm just
wondering why it is that
you know
healthcare professionals
have expressed that they've been denied
access to n95s people entering hospital
are told not to wear their n95 and are
given the blue surgical mask
i just
can you explain
why
the province is so staunchly opposed to
allowing people to wear n95s in
healthcare settings um and and can you
also explain why measures like hand
washing and plexiglas barriers are more
effective at preventing transmission
than an n95 respirator
yeah so i think that's part of the crux
of the issue right there they uh
barriers hand hygiene they're all layers
of protection respirators are a layer of
protection so it's not one is more
effective than the other they all need
to be in place in different settings and
risk is different in different settings
we have always
understood that and i've talked for a
year and a half to now since we've
understood this more
in more in much more detail about where
things are are riskier and so indoor
settings when you're crowded together
when people are doing certain things in
a healthcare setting we have what we
call hierarchies of control so there's a
whole variety of steps that are taken
to prevent transmission of infections
including covid and that includes
depending on the setting
the appropriate risk assessment and
wearing of of respirators when needed
but when we're talking about visitors
and patients going into a healthcare
setting with a mask that they may have
got in the community we don't have an
understanding of the quality of that
personal mask how well it's been cared
for so we do require people to use
the standard quality new
medical masks that are
very effective along with the other
measures that are in place in healthcare
settings at preventing transmission of
infection so this is a whole spectrum of
things and depending on the setting
there's a different
level that's needed of different types
of protection and the same goes for
plexiglass barriers in uh in the grocery
store if we're face to face with
somebody
we know that that that is where you're
likely to be exposed to more of the
potentially infectious droplets and so
having a barrier
is effective along with wearing masks
along with keeping distance along with
ventilation so it's not one or the other
it is having all of those layers of
protection in the community and the
hierarchy controls in our affection
prevention and control programs in all
healthcare settings
we have time for one more question we'll
go to benite breach cbc
hi dr henry um as we look towards a
gradual listing of restrictions in the
next couple of weeks how much
flexibility is being built into the
future plan how quickly will bc be able
to respond when the next variant of
concern presents itself and can we
please get an answer in french as well
yeah you know those are things that
we've been looking at very closely
particularly you know i talk about how
we are looking at what's happening in
different scenarios around the world and
around the country and and even within
bc so it is important we're um much of
our our planning already and what we
need to plan for going forward is based
on contingencies and
having
looking at different scenarios that
might happen so for example i i think
it's unlikely from what we've been
seeing that we'll need to do a broad
immunization program for everybody in
the future but i think it is a
probability that changes um as we're
going through the months and into
respiratory season that we may have to
immunize those people who are most
vulnerable and we know that's our elders
and seniors and the very young so we
need to be able to plan for that
another thing that's really really
important is we've seen that
much of our
restrictions that we've had in place
have been because we we've not had the
capacity in our health care system and
we saw that vividly in the north during
the delta wave
so being able to take the time that we
have when when transmission is low to
try and
ensure we're building up our health care
system increasing our capacity um so
that we have that surge capacity when it
when it's inevitably going to be needed
is something that
i know the ministry and the minister
we're working on so those are all
contingency plans that we're looking at
what we would like to be
and i think we're moving to that place
through this transition period is never
having to go back to broad societal
and that's what we
you know what we're planning to what are
the things that we need to have in place
so that we don't have to do those things
again and we've recognized and we have
seen in this last two years how
important and how interconnected
everything is whether it's keeping
schools open and child care open so that
people can work because
making sure that you are able to to put
food on the table is a such an important
part of our mental and physical and
emotional health so all of those things
are interconnected and being able to
provide people with the care that they
need in our health care system
whether it's from whatever is causing
the latest infection or whether it's
care for everything else is also really
important so yeah those are really
important um
machinations and why we're taking a a
slowly progressive and thoughtful
approach to how we get through this next
few weeks and months
[Music]
flexibility
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
specialist
[Music]
possibility
did you have a follow-up
yes please after dr henry given that now
typically healthy people are being told
they can wait up to three months after
omicron infection before getting a
booster do you think that might account
for the number of booster dose
appointments that are going unfulfilled
right now a lot of people unfilled sorry
a lot of people in bc had on the crown
in january and can we get an answer in
french as well
yeah i i think that's part of it
i know the pharmacy association and our
immunization programs have been
asking people you know what is the
reason and we've been
trying to understand why some people
aren't booking um when even when they're
eligible part of it is that there's a
group of people that are not yet
eligible at that six months and
that interval is important um some
people are absolutely they
they've had their two doses and they
think that's enough um there are people
who
uh have had infection recently and yes
we do now know that
if you're vaccinated it can give you a
good uh boost but it's not as long
lasting so getting that booster is
important and it's a it's a challenging
thing to know um as i mentioned the
advice from nasi is is complex and in
the fine print it says you know we don't
actually know yet what the optimal
interval is between an infection and
um getting your your your next dose um
and it depends a lot on the situation
you are in so i
would encourage people even if you've
had uh omicron in the last month if
you're at that six-month place and
you're healthy
you know you can wait as long as
three extra months
but
if you're in a situation where you have
others around you who are more at risk
or if you're in
a congregate living setting for example
or in a community where there's a lot of
people at risk
then it's good to get that booster now
because we are now seeing that it does
provide additional protection against
infection and it provides a good strong
boost to your cell-mediated immunity for
the future
and and just say that the number of
appointments available is partly the the
massive response both by public health
and by our pharmacy sector and our
pharmacist has done an exceptional job
in providing and making available
booster shots across bc
and certainly if you look over 65 for
example about 78 percent of people have
received their booster doses that's 78
on the 91 who received their second
doses who are eligible so that is
roughly 86 of that group
who have received their booster shots
shot so that's a that's an impressive
number it's less in
uh in other age categories partly
because of the six-month criteria partly
because
um uh there are some there are clearly
appointments open and people waiting for
they get their booster dose and i just
uh say to all to everyone today there is
an opportunity to do so it makes you
safer your community safer everyone's
safer and to get your booster doses and
we're going to continue to uh
to promote that booster doses for people
for
um
including for those who are starting to
get them in the 12 to 17
category as well as first and second
doses
right now for those five to eleven for
children five to eleven right now we're
at uh roughly 54 percent of that group
receive their first dose immunization
roughly 10 or 11 their second dose
because that's just started happening
and we want to continue to encourage
that as a way to make all of
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
we'll see you next tuesday
you